-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
And now we're going to
get to the news.
Former president Barack Obama
today visited the White House.
And out of habit, Jeanine Pirro
called for his impeachment.
[ Laughter ]
During a Zoom call last summer
with a group
of presidential historians,
former president Trump
reportedly imitated the accent
of the president of South Korea.
Alright, I'm not surprised
he did something
horribly offensive.
I am a little surprised
he did it
on a call with
presidential historians.
[ As Trump ] So, you guys
will be evaluating me
for posterity, right?
Okay.
Then you're gonna love this.
Two lesbians walk into a bar.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
President Biden said yesterday
that Russian president
Vladimir Putin
should face a war crimes trial
for his recent actions
in Ukraine.
Good luck to whoever pulls that
in jury duty.
[ Laughter ]
"Is there any reason
why you shouldn't be selected
for this case?"
"Um, I got a wife and kids."
[ Laughter ]
The Senate Judiciary
Committee's vote
to move Ketanji Brown Jackson's
nomination out of committee
was delayed yesterday because
California senator Alex Padilla
was forced to switch
to a later flight.
Look, I don't care if the fate
of the Supreme Court
hangs in the balance.
They offer you $400 in
flight credits, you take it.
[ Laughter ]
Probably a food voucher.
An environmental group
said in a new report
that it cleaned up nearly
half a million pieces of trash
last year
from New Jersey beaches,
including a fake eyeball.
Wow.
I am shocked.
That it was fake.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I feel like most days
you go to the Jersey Shore,
you're seeing a real eyeball.
[ Laughter ]
The environmental group
also reported
finding male enhancement pills
and a glow-in-the-dark condom,
or as it's known in New Jersey,
solid Tuesday night.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
regular Fox News viewers
who were paid to watch CNN
for 30 days
became more skeptical and less
likely to believe fake news.
Said one participant,
"Before this,
I didn't even know some women
had brown hair."
[ Laughter ]
Crazy.
According to the latest numbers,
the average price for a slice
of pizza in New York City
is now more expensive
than riding the subway.
And for both things,
it's a good idea
to soak up the grease
with a napkin first.
[ Laughter, groaning ]
I mean, I don't --
I don't quite know what we're --
what we want from the audience
when we tell a joke like that.
[ Laughter ]
That was a very fair and
accurate response by all of you.
Every now and then, we like
to set the levels, you know.
We don't say a joke so much
as just a truly disgusting idea.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
16% of Americans
live in the same city or town
that they grew up in.
The other 84% have them muted
on Facebook.
[ Laughter ]
In anticipation
of legal marijuana
being available later this year,
New York governor Kathy Hochul
yesterday
unveiled the state's
Cannabis Conversations campaign,
which I'm guessing is that thing
where the edible kicks in
and you end up
debating your cat.
[ Laughter ]
"I think you're hard
to be around."
[ Laughter ]
"Okay."
The "New York Post"
recently reported
that at least 139 people
around the country
have said they became sick
after eating the breakfast
cereal Lucky Charms,
or as they're now known,
just Charms.
[ Laughter ]
A restaurant in Florida
reportedly canceled
a dinner reservation recently
after discovering the gathering
was a going-away party
for a Capitol rioter
who was sentenced to prison.
Alright, but don't be shocked
if they show up anyway.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, authorities
in Florida announced yesterday
that they arrested six men
who allegedly stole thousands
of dollars' worth of gasoline
from several gas stations.
They would have gotten away, but
thousands of dollars of gasoline
was still only
like a quarter tank.
[ Laughter ]
That was the monologue,
everybody.